[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in daniel jeremiah
he's a former scout with the ravens
browns eagles
he's a nfl network analyst he was
working the game last night that we'll
get to let me start with uh what you
thought of taysom hill when he came out
of college
uh sure dan i thought he was first of
all i felt like i evaluated him nine
years in a row
because every year you'd go to byu and
looking at me like they got this kid
take them
it'll be his last year and he'd get hurt
he'd come back for another year
and another year and another year so but
the evaluation was
honestly was he was a faster scott frost
which was
remember scott coming out he made the
transition to safety and the thought was
this guy's a tremendous athlete
we just don't i mean he just runs around
back there for the most part so
you know we can use him in a variety of
roles special teams maybe you can
develop him into a safety
but i i for one did not view him as a
you know future nfl starting quarterback
i don't know anybody that was scouting
him that did at that time
why is sean payton all in on taysom hill
i think he's had a certain playbook that
he's been
limited to with drew and i think he's
been curious to see how he could expand
it and
the creativity he could bring to sean to
kind of invigorate him a little bit so i
think that's been something that's an
itch he's wanted to scratch
and uh you know i was curious i was
anxious to see if they would give him
this opportunity because
i was beginning to think that taysom
hill was going to have a lifetime in the
sidecar and never get to be in the
motorcycle
just just he's always going to be the
other quarterback along with your
starter
instead of being the starter and now
you're getting a chance to see let's see
what he can do with uh with an entire
game
or two here but he's 30. can you teach
somebody to play the position at 30
he's a young 30 dan he's a young 30.
he's gonna be like mileage no he's got a
lot of mileage he's an old 30 i think
no i mean well i don't know we're going
to find out
there's nothing to compare this to we
don't really have anything in history to
go back to compare it to i just know
um man he is he is he's dynamic with the
ball in his hands when he takes off and
runs my question is
doing that on a part-time basis he's
been able to stay healthy can he stay
healthy doing that on a full-time basis
okay if you could have tebow or take
some hill
tebow i think ran high four sixes low
four sevens taysom hill is a 4-4
i mean like he's a totally different
level of athlete than tim tebow why is
tebow not in the league
he's a he's a quarterback that can't
throw dan that's that's not a great
combination
so that would be why other than that
how was the play mrs lincoln but but
okay
this felt like this was common knowledge
but people were still
denver takes him first round josh
mcdaniels takes him first round
yeah i mean but you can talk yourself
into tebow as a passer in college i mean
even though
you know there was issues with his
delivery there was issues with the you
know when you just watched him
mechanically
but if you want to look at the stats and
the numbers you say okay well he played
the sec you know
completion percentage yards wins all
that stuff all piled up and you can say
hey
he made that skill set work in the best
conference in college football maybe we
can get him to make it work in the nfl
so
i can see how they kind of talk
themselves into that
yeah it's it's still baffling because
tebow's what 32 now
but if if you said to tebow hey we're
going to make you a tight end
like tebow would still be in the league
wouldn't he
i don't know i i don't know if he was
that type of an athlete i feel like the
jets and
and uh the patriots kind of wanted to
get him worked into some of those areas
and it just didn't
it didn't really happen so i don't know
i think that was kind of the easy thing
to say for all those years like if he
had just played fullback or tight end h
back that he'd be still going and i
i don't think that i don't think that's
necessarily the case
what have you seen with kyler murray
that's different than
how you viewed him when he was coming
out of college
well i mean i i was i kind of was he was
an acquired taste for me in college and
i just got to the point where i was like
i cannot deny
how good this guy has been you know even
you know you look at some of the
the size issues limitations of the
limited uh play time whatever you want
to
look at negatively but did you have more
questions about kyler
or baker mayfield i thought kyler was a
much better player than baker mayfield
so
kyler i had a higher grade on coming out
so um but he's been
you know i i was i got to the point
where by draft day i was excited about
what he could do and he still exceeded
that somebody was asking me the other
day
for you know the comparison for kyler
murray i'm like there's not really an
easy comparison i guess the only thing i
could say would be
you know if you left patrick mahomes in
the dryer for too long and strapped a
jet pack to his back
that's kind of the way kyler murray
plays i mean he's just a little little
miniature version of patrick mahomes
with a little more juice
but i wonder what we saw with seattle
last night and you were doing the game
seattle seemed to have a little bit more
of an aggressive approach and that is we
want to dictate what you're going to do
before
you dictate what we're going to do is
that the blueprint do you think
well they did a good job with the zone
reading so what they did is they just
said
you're gonna have to give the ball
because we're gonna we're gonna account
for the quarterback on every single zone
read
so they kind of eliminated that portion
of what he can do with his athleticism
but dan i thought when his shoulder when
he got crunched in the first half
i don't think he really looked to run i
don't think he looked to create there
were times where they were rushing three
on some third downs
and usually when you rush three against
a very athletic quarterback you're
begging him to go take off and run and
get some of those free yards and he
never really even looked to do it so
i'm going to kind of put that game on a
little bit on the side there in terms of
an evaluation of kyler because i did not
think he was he was right there with his
shoulder
and with russell wilson was it just size
that's why he didn't go in the first or
second round yeah i mean i can remember
where i was sitting at the senior bowl
when the weigh-ins happened and
a lot of us had got to the point where
we were like okay we were hoping he was
going to be six feet tall but we had
convinced ourselves
he's going to be 5 11 and change and you
know we're that's okay we'll we'll get
through that and then they said 5
10 6. and then we all kind of looked at
each other we're like oh man like you
get in the draft room
selling 510 it sounds silly but selling
510
is a lot more difficult than selling 511
at that time it sounds stupid but it's
absolutely true because i can remember
somebody in the room
high up in the room where i was with the
eagles just saying who were the
comparisons who
who were the five foot 10 quarterbacks
and you're like well you get doug flutie
i mean that's
that's about it but if if russ was
coming out
now given kyler's success
where is russell first round top five
top five pick
really oh yeah because you would sit in
there and you would read your reports on
russell wilson dan and you would be like
where the where are the negatives here
you know he's got a live arm he's a
great athlete he's smart he's tough
competitive
he's been productive at a high level you
know like there was and even the size
thing there wasn't really
you never watched the tape of wisconsin
and left a game thinking you know what
gosh man his
his size really hurt him in that one it
was really an issue it wasn't
but it was just trying to get past the
you know the history of not having
one of those to compare him to that's
that's what it was and that would have
been gone
and i wonder i've i've said that steph
curry will probably have a
longer lasting impact on the nba skill
wise than michael jordan because we
can't be michael jordan
but everybody feels like they could be
steph curry i wonder if russell wilson's
impact on the nfl is going to be he
opened the door for every one of these
quarterbacks who were
six feet or under i don't think it's
just the nfl i think you can go to
college into high school
i think if you went into some of the you
know big high schools in texas or
florida in california and you had a kid
that went out there for tryouts and was
five nine five ten and was infinitely
better than the six foot three six foot
four kid
those big high schools wouldn't even
give the the smaller kid a chance
and say no no you that's that's that's
not going to work we're going to go with
the bigger kid and we'll try and develop
him to see what he can be
and we've seen that trickle all the way
up uh you know
kyler murray does kyle does kyler murray
you know to see
at that huge high school at allen texas
is he even playing quarterback there at
that time
if we don't have some of the success of
some of these smaller guys much less now
we're looking around the ncaa
i think alabama's got a freshman that
they signed out of modern day high
school
bryce young who's six foot or below
he'll be he'll be starting alabama
here in a year for he'll run that
program for three years he's daniel
jeremiah nfl network analyst and former
nfl scout he does the chargers games
by the way how do you think the haircut
with justin herbert is going to affect
his performance here daniel
i haven't had anything negative to say
about justin all year long he's been
phenomenal
bye john lot john lott's a really good
strength coach but
you know you don't ask strength coaches
to cut your hair i mean that's just
there's simple rules you live by dan and
that's got to be one of them so that's
the first poor decision justin's really
made
yeah i agree when do you start analyzing
the college football
players i'm working through offensive
lineman right now
so this kind of uh i like to go
positions at a time so right now i'm
really kind of getting cranked into it
and then looking at the offensive line
so it's kind of it's kind of apropos
thanksgiving's coming up it makes you
really hungry when you watch a bunch of
big guys
but but do you build up to the
quarterback what position
is the final position yeah usually the
quarterback i try and save towards the
end but there are sometimes you get into
a lull
where you're like man i gotta get some i
gotta go pick me up here and the and the
quarterbacks are my favorite thing to do
so once we uh
uh once we get to that point where i'm
gonna need a little juice then i'll
start really diving in
aside from the obvious who are the
quarterback candidates who
might surprise us that they might be a
day one
or maybe a day two but keep an eye on
well i mean byu zack wilson is everybody
in the league loves that kid
so there is uh he's he's got a lot a lot
of uh
what what is it that he has that what
does he do better than trevor lawrence
or justin fields
i think it's just a creative playmaker
um and i've seen i've i've looked at one
game on him so i've just looked at one
game he's got a live
loose arm um i i think some of the
things that that
this is the patrick mahomes effect of
being able to play you know some doing
some things outside the structure of the
offense
he does those extremely well while you
know not being
you know overboard with it not being a
little reckless he's just got some of
that play-making ability that's got a
lot of people fired up and excited
anybody else i i like what i'm seeing
with trask
he seems like a tough kid that he's
going to take a hit but he'll stay in
there in the throw
um but i always wonder about this daniel
and you know this better than me
i want to see what you do after an
interception i want to see what you do
after you get sacked like in college
everybody's completing 80
of their passes it feels like i want to
see when something bad happens to you
how important is that because in the
pros you're eventually going to get
humbled
yeah i mean look look at joe burrow i
mean that was kind of his signature play
from the year before
right when he has the interception he
gets drilled and then comes back and
plays lights out the rest of that game
and then really never looked back the
rest of his career
um but the challenge and ozzie newsom
used to always say this
in the in the combine interviews was he
wanted to get to the adversity that
these kids have faced
not just on the field but off the field
and what they've done to overcome that
because when you look at the bus and we
kind of all know who those guys are for
the most part
dealing with adversity is the number one
reason why these quarterbacks don't make
it because
they haven't had much they haven't had
much through high school or college you
know talking on the field
and then when they face that adversity
how are you going to handle it so
trying to see that and trying to
diagnose that not only on the field but
off the field is a
key part of whether or not these guys
are going to make it is trevor lawrence
going to be rated higher than joe burrow
i i think there's probably a good chance
of that because of just the added
dimension of what he can do as a runner
um you know he's pretty special in that
gilberto is pretty good at that too joe
burrow is a good physical runner uh
trevor lawrence has got just more juice
jill burroughs joe bro is gonna
fight his way for 15 yards and trevor
lawrence ran away from ohio state so
that that's the
that's a little difference there boy but
to go to the jets
i'm not as down on the jets dan let me
give you let me
let me give you my positivity for the
jets here you probably just put a
commercial while i'm talking no
no no you're mr positivity i'm all ears
here so the
going to the jets is going to be a great
thing for trevor lawrence because
because i've studied them this week
because they play the chargers
so the left tackle makai bechten who we
loved in the draft is going to be the
best left tackle in the nfl within
within the next two years okay
denzel mims who's played who's been on
the field for the last three or four
weeks looks
looks outstanding he's going to be a
really good number two wide receiver
so there's a couple pieces there you can
work with on offense they've got i think
the second most cap space of any team in
the league
they're going to have the first overall
pick they're going to get trevor
they're going to have seattle's pick
which is going to be somewhere in the
20s
they're going to have the 33rd pick the
first pick of the second round
and i believe they're going to trade if
they have the first pick they'll trade
sam donald and i
i firmly believe they'll get a 1. so
you're going to have four the top 33
picks
to add in around him a boatload of money
and free agency to go out and get you
know the bud duprees or you know whoever
else the courtesy and any guys you want
they're in free agency
so i think you can turn around pretty
quick they need to get the right coach i
mean in my opinion they got to go
find the right coach but i think that
actually is a chance to turn around
with jets but if you're eric be enemy
and i said take your pick
i'm coaching trevor lawrence if i'm
american okay all right because i don't
want to go to houston
as much as i like deshawn watson i think
that organization's a mess
well the good news about houston is that
if you want an extra day off you can
take it unfortunately it's a day the
first day the draft
wow but what about atlanta
would you be interested in coaching the
falcons
you know i would be curious to see what
their thought process is because i think
you could go two ways you could say
we still have you know with julio with
matt ryan and some of these
key pieces ridley's a really good player
would you keep matt ryan
i think you have to with salary cap for
another year okay so
so but are you going to try and maybe
make a little run here with this group
last time or is it a gut job and you're
coming in there trying to really
you know go to the ground floor and
build it back up that's something i
think that any coach that goes
on the interview is going to need to
figure out yeah it is pretty fascinating
that
the enemy can have i think you know when
the texans said that they might be or
somebody reported they might just give
it to romeo cornell for another year
i thought that that said a whole lot
that they know they can't get eric the
enemy
in houston so why not just have romeo
one more year
can't be interviewing people due to
covid probably
and it's an odd year so why not turn it
over or keep it with romeo cornell
yeah you know and and look i i do want
to mention with houston that
you have desean watson so even the fact
you don't have draft picks you've got
some
salary cap issues and roster issues man
there
there could be worse things than the to
get to coach him on a yearly basis but i
just think there's a little bit of a
mess you got to kind of clean up there
with some other areas who had the flower
arrangement behind you who's
this is a nfl network uh production back
here
and the other thing is dan do the bricks
look real or fake to you fake
100 yeah wallpaper um i know we've
i know fake because all i have to do is
look over the other side of the glass
and i see fakes oh you've got bricks
you've got bricks behind you
are those fakes they are uh cut in half
they're they're not full bricks they're
uh surface bricks okay i think the
i think that the oakland uh coliseum has
those as you walk out into the field
those little you need your finisher you
need helmets in there you need books in
there
i know but i feel like you know i i
thought about just kind of to have some
fun like putting my son's
little league trophies back here you
know kurt's got his mvps and his nfl
manager here what if i just put like a
little
little league trophy why don't you get
your jersey didn't you play college
football
yeah but i mean like does any i mean my
appalachian state jersey gonna give me a
lot more credibility right behind me yes
it will
yes it will yes given what your display
is back there
yes it will daniel yes oh
hey great i get a lot of compliments on
these flowers i'll have you know a lot
of them
no my wife would like them i mean i i
think that
she would really like those that's very
nice uh great to talk to you thanks for
getting up for uh
the appearance here and uh great to talk
to you thank you daniel
thanks dan see both that's daniel
jeremiah nfl network analyst and if
you're watching on peacock you could see
how bad that
kind of that background area was with
daniel